yeah ready
oh my God
it's on fire that's so hot
[Music]
[Music]
stuffed crust pizza was one of the
greatest scientific achievements of the
90s how can we take one of the world's
cheesiest dishes and somehow stuff it
with even more cheese well today I'm
facing off against Tick-Tock Phenom
Sally slices to see if we can turn the
most kid-friendly meal and pizza into
something elevated and Gourmet our
judges today are Pizza Lovers Show Low
maridwenya for the hit series Cobra Kai
and pro wrestler Rick Baker from the aew
well our pizza is packing a punch to
knock out sholo and bread let's get
ready to rumble
we've got Sal AKA Sally slices in the
building welcome to Pizza World cool
thank you for having me give me a holler
oh you're so sweet so one of the things
I love about your Tick Tock is that you
started it to bring attention to your
Pizzeria just tell us how you got
started I was working six days a week 12
hours a day and I had no sense of life I
was just doing something you know to
make my family proud then you're not
gonna introduce the tick tock I started
posting little by little and out of
nowhere blew up we have people coming
from Texas California Wisconsin
it's I am so blessed and I tell my
mother and my father every day that it
wasn't me it was all of us so we made
something beautiful happen
all right so I'm so excited to see what
you're gonna do today with the stuffed
crust pizza what you got going on
clinical before I start thank you for
having me again oh yes give me one one
more hug for good luck
thank you pleasure I love everyone great
face straight all right it's business
and I'm gonna look mean I never actually
made a stuffed crust pizza before but
that was the theme for the show and I
jumped right on it because it's
something different and I like different
so what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
make a pizza I'm going to stuff the
crust with Grande fresh mozzarella only
the best and then each side I'm gonna
put a little bit of a topping with the
with the cheese you know for the tits
the way I look at it this pizza's like a
baby it needs its vegetables it needs
its protein it needs its Dairy needs
everything to make it a full pot okay so
you get the pizza first
Pat it out nicely nice treat it gentle
do with the heart you see nice and nice
so what we want to do here is we want to
kill the crust so it's easier to overlap
when we put the cheese on okay but I've
been done okay
so now when you have the crust killed
you want to get the loafs of cheese how
do you feel about pepperoni I love the
love though I'm gonna do some nice
pepperoni at the top one look at that
just let that you fold that over so
that's the first okay so now for it the
left side you get the nice cheese sticks
that we did before okay I'm gonna put
some sausage because
the pizza needs protein oh and then next
we're gonna give it the mushrooms for
its vegetables okay the bottom is just
going to be cheese you know this is for
the family you've got to remember some
people just like cheese okay so I also
notice you don't have any sauce no sauce
this is going to be white I love this
because as you know you're already
overwhelming with a lot of different
toppings and stuff crust you don't want
to put too much Adam at once yeah so
Nicole once we have everything stuffed
up we did a nice and comfortable on the
paddle make sure she's loose which she
is yes she is we put her in
[Music]
my first stuffed crust pizza
it looks cheesy and delicious all right
next we're not done yet okay we're gonna
do the arugula first some arugula in the
middle oh it looks beautiful it's a
little bird's nest after that put some
sharp provolone
last thin is the prosciutto oh man the
prosciutto nice and nice on there all
right Nicole it's all done what do you
think oh it looks beautiful beautiful
right Cheers Cheers Nicole so first
things first I gotta try the crust
when you bite our bite
one two three
[Music]
it's cheesy and delicious a lot of
cheesy we wanted this stuffed crust we
made this stuff Christmas this is what
the kids love I love it
we need we need the reaction Nicole what
is it it's delicious good good I think
this is great for adults and kids
actually I'm having fun eating it yeah
having fun deciding how I want to eat it
do I want to break the crust do I want
to roll it up do I want to hold it like
a slice tastes delicious yeah thank you
forgot it's never made a stuffed crust
pizza before I think that this came out
seven and a half out of ten I think it's
appetizing with spilling there's not too
much cheese there's a perfect amount of
condiments
then a 7.5 now I think I'm happy with
this you know what you're telling my
book no you're the best Nicole yeah Sal
this was incredible blew my mind but
I've got something special for you you
ready I was born ready let's see it I
could tell
so today I'm doing more of like an adult
stuffed crust pizza have you ever had
the star stuffed crust pizzas before I
have to say I don't think I've ever had
I've never had either and guess what
I've never made it either just like me
so we're both first
I'm gonna make it right here for the
first time so if I mess up take it easy
on me but our ingredients are going to
be kind of similar so step one we're
just gonna open this up
okay so now I'm gonna cut these into my
little stars I don't know why I had to
pick something so complicated
so what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to take a little ricotta that I put a
little spicy honey in okay I like that I
never heard of that and I'm gonna put a
dollop on each slice boom and then I'm
gonna take these cubed mozzarella
because this is going to be my cheesy
part okay and I'm just going to put it
right in the middle and let me try one
so I take this
and I think I fold it like this
and I fold it like that I think that's
the star oh it's going to be like a sun
I'm gonna do that all the way around the
crust because it's my first time I'm
just gonna part bake it a little first
and then come take it out good idea all
right we've car baked it and now it's
time to finish the topping so what we're
going to do is we're gonna put a little
tomato on here
not too much just a little and I'm gonna
add some cheese I'm just gonna go ahead
and put a lot of cheese in the center
like that
and I'm just gonna pop it back in
because everything afterwards is just
like a topping okay what do you think
beautiful that came out perfect you
think so yeah extra extra cheesy the
best that's what I thought would be good
I'm gonna put some nice arugula down
boom and then I'm gonna put some onions
because I just like a little onion I
don't know Tomatoes I'm just gonna put
some on here
just for some color nice and crispy
prosciutto
gotta have some Cracked Pepper
this all for you sound I'm so excited
and then
grated Parmesan what really makes it an
adult pies we got some chili oil oh yeah
this is gonna put some chili oil all
over that especially on the crust and
that's it that looks beautiful Nicole
you like it it looks beautiful I think
I'm gonna take this competition looks
good Put a Little Slice on here for you
yeah
that looks amazing right cheers
oh McCoy one up to straight to this
pizza
the bed
from you I'm golden let me try this
cheese you crust
so Nicole what I love about it is that
you put so many good ingredients on it
but it's all separated perfectly the
cheese and the crust that was the
perfect amount thank you the chili oil
was a beautiful touch and I love how it
got crunchy too it's perfect texture
everything all around I love it coming
from you style where you do everything
from your heart all that really matters
thank you so we have two amazing judges
today we got sholo from Cobra Kai we've
got Brit Baker pro wrestler from the aew
wow I'm excited let's see what that me
too I think they're gonna throw down I
think they're gonna throw down I think
so we got one that does karate one that
does the wrestling all right let's go
bring in the pies no but really oh
[Music]
look that that's when you know see that
that's when we're in it kind of looks
like a baby croissant on the end
I'll say some Tomatoes all right at the
same time yeah which end are we starting
with though oh because we got the crust
and the pizza yeah we can do one bite
and then one bite Cheers Cheers okay
[Music]
whoa that's bad that's real good that
one's really good usually I don't like
cherry tomatoes because well when I have
them whole and salads they just burst in
your mouth and it feels a little
intrusive but these
are already cut up so there's not
they're not flavored
flavor profile is just Immaculate all
right you ready for getting antsy yeah
ready
how did you do that whoa
it's distinctly a different type of
cheese see I'm a big ricotta fan so for
me this is great it's really hot so I
need to like give it a second so I can
properly taste it because I think I
scorched 80 of my taste buds off so
we're gonna let's now the next pizza's
gonna lose because I can't taste the
other one this is 10 out of 10. what
made me so excited about this stuffed
crust is I haven't had it in so long
like it's something I remember so
distinctly about my childhood like
stuffed crust pizza but I don't it's
like a lost art you finished the pizza
and then some people don't even like the
crust some people yeah I used to be
someone who didn't like it but you if
you if it's loaded with cheese and
garlic and oil you're gonna eat it all
right you ready where's this next Pizza
dog let's do it let's do it where's it
at where is she at
okay Britt this is our second pizza how
full are you are you ready I'm not
pulling okay yeah okay we're we're gonna
head right into it no commentary only
Pizza I don't see any sauce I believe
that it's in there though there's no
sauce no sauce oh snap whoever made this
pizza is like hey
you guys said stuffed crust so the whole
pizza is the crust yeah but I'm not
knocking it I gotta try it I'm gonna
yeah of course
I love that look at this look at this
this is it's giving me like calzone
Vibes yeah this is a big ass boy okay
let's go on okay just eat it okay
oh again it's hot for me I like this but
I could definitely not eat two slices of
this and I need I need sauce for me okay
but the mushrooms and the cheese mixed
together like this is like the actual
crust part is one of my favorite stuffed
crusts I've ever had even though there's
no sauce yeah the oil does have a lot of
flavor like the cheese oil or whatever
it is on top and the bottom is crispy
and I love crispy bottom Pizza
um but it's so much crust but this is a
big boy this is huge
this decision is pretty hard I think we
should see the contestants so that we
can see their anguish and defeat when we
announce the winner really look in their
eyes we need to look in their eyes
hello Britt thank you so much joining us
on Pizza Wars thank you very much
so Sal and I we had a ball earlier
making these pies for you guys that was
a lot of fun yeah we did yeah with that
said we're here for serious business us
tell us which part did you like the most
okay so it was close but I think I think
we've come to a decision let me see
yeah yeah you think so exactly all right
I agree I agree I agree okay you ready
yeah should we count it down yeah okay
three two
[Music]
okay
I'm really shocked because I thought
Sally really got this one well thank you
guys so much wow thank you thank you so
much
so I I I'm really a little shocked
congratulations oh yes girl
Sal you gave me a run for my money
I had a lot of fun thank you for having
me well come back anytime of course all
right see you next time on pizza wars
ciao
[Music]
[Music]